so i just had a wonderful
wonderful discussion here with my friend
about
needing to find a balance between the
practical
and the poetry in our lives the
practical is
doing your homework the practical is
fetching water and chopping wood the
practical is meeting your
responsibilities but the poetry is
seeing in your song the poetry is
marching to the beat of your own drummer
you know the poetry is the thing that
lights you up the poetry is your
intuition your love of flow and
adventure
in other words your poetry is often the
impractical and so we're told
to
meet deadlines and to
meet our responsibilities and i
understand this messaging but i think
that often this messaging tells us that
our poetry is fundamentally impractical
and that we should choose the practical
um potentially in more uh spiritual
circles we are encouraged to pay
attention to the poetry as well we are
told to
find a balance between the practical and
the poetry to meet each halfway and so
on and so forth and that very well that
very may well be true that we might find
a way to
to to to be both practical and
to be both practical and poetry
but sometimes the answer is paradoxical
sometimes the most practical thing we
can do sometimes the most practical
thing we need is actually something
that's not practical at all now that
sounds like an oxymoron it sounds like a
paradox that sometimes
the most practical intervention the
thing you need the most practically
speaking for your mental health is to do
the impractical thing is to do the
poetic thing only to take the leap as
terence mckenna said nature loves
courage you make the commitment and
nature responds to that commitment by
removing impossible obstacles this is
where it gets metaphysical you dream the
impossible dream the impractical dream
and the world will not grind you under
it will lift you up this is they say the
secret what all the philosophers the
teachers the wise men the shamans those
who really touched the alchemical gold
those who really understood this is what
they understood this is how magic is
done this is the shamanic dance in the
waterfall you you you leap into the
abyss you hurl yourself into the abyss
and you realize that it's a feather bed
and so how can this be
how can sometimes the most practical
thing be the poetry be the impractical
thing well it's like that scene
in the movie eat pray love when the main
character elizabeth gilbert played by
julia roberts has broken up with her new
love and she's telling her
her shaman
that she ended it and then he says why
you do that liz why you do that why you
end
your relationship and she says i lost my
balance right it just wasn't practical
you know she had her yoga she had her
breath work she had her journaling she
had her medication she spent this whole
year finding balance and then she falls
in love with this guy and she loses her
balance completely in the throngs of
love and so now she ends it because why
because it's not practical and you know
what the shaman says liz
sometimes losing balance for love is
part of living a balanced life and so to
that end sometimes losing your
for poetry sometimes losing your
practical
for poetry
is exactly the practical thing to do and
it's what you need in living a practical
life that sometimes becoming poetry
is
necessary for a practical and a healthy
life and i thought that was really
interesting because it resolves the
paradox the moment you realize that
um
it's it's reconciliatory
it's when thesis and antithesis are
resolved by synthesis that sometimes the
most practical thing
is the most impractical and most poetic
thing
after all
sometimes losing balance for love is
part of living a balanced life
so there you go